welcome to this video I'm playing and
through the st 88 from from the US and
we have a French Steinitz i recently
lost a really really drastic game here
on the channel okay not against the
smooth which i never have seen joe i can
i can win the porn try to keep it okay
so what exactly is White's point my term
yeah i can try to to get it back of
course maybe I should just block
everything here if he takes Knight eggs
I'm i get some get active it gets
activated again okay so he wants to play
before but should be two and then regain
the pond I see ya okay if I go a five be
three yeah well I don't know it's some
it's probably a playable in the playable
on line that is going for now b6 Bishop
a six I like to get this bishops of the
board
okay you will get the phone back right
so nothing to be done about it
yeah my idea is that here I'm getting
this the e4 square so if he does not
take or he must take on c5 now I get you
formed yeah I really thought you it was
mandatory to take okay maybe I should
have taken actually okay but he takes
himself this is even better okay so i
must be a must be a precise here only
has one idea left as a seafoam and if i
managed to avoid that then yeah ok so
now black is strategically winning i
only need to avoid getting mated or
blundering like ooh k 7 roocase seven
would be really awful okay let's do it
like that I'm strategically winning you
because of the pawn structure you've got
everything on dark squares and I have
this fantastic night but ok there's
still the possibility that I I blunder
or overlooked some tactic whatever
exchanging the Queen's and obviously
would be fantastic how to do that maybe
get the Queen over to age 62 h 5 can be
helpful
yeah maybe Queen to age six and then
possibly rook c7 rook see to f7 piling
up on the pawn okay i have roots III m
if I if I want you know i don't i don't
see why not Queen to h3 would be a nice
move really yeah come on very hard now
to not tear eight queens yeah need to do
play something like that some may be
here to be five hangs again okay it's
not somewhat tricky it still is
because it's not so apparent how to how
to break through okay maybe you can
regroup again go into f5 and Roxy seven
yeah i don't i don't see em how i'm
actually winning still not easy to break
through
yeah maybe get the Queen maybe Brooke
both looks on the afar quinta c4 I don't
know I need to need to find the right
setup here which i didn't manage yet I
now threatening book takes to form a
neat little trick maybe this helps it
didn't okay look at five queen of 8s my
regrouping and idea
Queenie eight then Roxy seven look f
seven yeah it's surprisingly difficult
doing for my regrouping plan but the
problem is right here what is my legs
smooth yeah cannot exchange here because
it takes with the pawn okay time warning
Gras our third it's it's still it's
still nice I don't see I don't see your
window I must admit that okay now the
king is covering the b5 poem I'm piling
up on the edge for pond I can't get this
covered okay there no way to break
through this sides that's crazy there
was some a threat yeah now I'll up here
check white forth in Santa still no meat
I can go to G for him and yeah i don't
know i mean it was such a great position
with this might only form but I didn't
find really a way to break through I
don't I don't think so I don't release I
don't really see it i mean if you give
it to the comp it's on minus two but
it's not should look at the lines it's
just shuffling around it's a is so nice
looking at this position
yeah I tried all kinds of her head
setups trying to force something maybe
11 way which I really didn't dare to do
I mean get getting the king over was an
idea okay so here may be here one idea
actually is to to to to to use the pawns
like this to force force things but I'm
not sure it was it was tricky to do
Bishop g1 and white is winning because
of this probably Wow winning really no
no it gives it wrong interesting
that's the line the computer is giving
yeah that's amazing and then what
happens if i take this Jack let's the
mate so I must do something against this
computer wants to play this check oops
no here yeah I don't don't understand
any of it yeah wow maybe I missed some
some concrete chance somewhere I don't
know so it's it's tricky and this is
such a great position and especially
after taking it's hard to believe
I don't I don't see I don't see it read
him okay well here the computer Gibson
in fact an improvement Roxy 6 what did I
play no I played that no I went here
computer wants to enter with the
Brooksie form yeah that's maybe a good
idea and now this I didn't play it badly
really I mean I always had this
disinherit pressure maybe he is the
pierced here's the moment here it is
this looked nice but it's not good the
best one is this getting Queens off okay
this is the real point yeah and now now
this is much better than then the game
with the Queen self because with the
Queen's off I don't need to worry about
be five anymore this is not a weakness
and here i can i can make progress
rather easily that's even this idea
entering yeah this is probably winning
the computer has a minus 2.2 it's always
on minus one point something in the
whole structure but this is even better
now yeah i have IDs and i can i can open
it up later with all the pawns on dark
square this is probably the way to go
alright thanks for watching